- [Voiceover] A store has
five different lengths
of extension cords for sale,
as shown in the table above.
If the range of lengths of
the five cords is seven feet,
what is the greatest possible value of X?
So the range is the difference
between the highest value
and the lowest value,
and we're trying to find the
greatest possible value of X,
then X should be the greatest value here.
And let's see if that can work out.
So let's just write the cord lengths,
and I just like to write 'em in order
just to visualize things.
So let's see, the lowest one is six feet,
and then we have a seven foot cord,
then we have an eight foot cord,
and then we have an 11 foot cord.
And then we have to X foot cord,
but let's not think
about that one just yet.
So if these were just
the four types of cords,
the range here would be
the high minus the low.
It would be 11 minus six,
which is equal to five.
Now, they tell us that the
real range is seven feet,
so that means we can
go even higher than 11.
And one way to think about it is,
if we're trying to maximize the value for,
if we need to maximize the value for X,
then we need to go seven
higher than the lowest value.
So the lowest value is six,
you go seven higher than
that, so plus seven,
you're going to get to 13.
So X, the highest possible
value for X is 13.
So X would be,
X would be equal to 13.
So X is 13 right over here.
Now, if someone were to say,
"What would be the lowest
possible value for X?"
you'd wanna go the other way around.
So if there's six, seven, 18, and 11,
and if you wanted to
minimize the value for X,
you wanna X as small as possible,
then you would say,
"Okay, well X is going to be the minimum
"of our cord lengths,"
and then you would take
seven less than the highest.
So 11 minus seven,
11 minus seven is going
to get you to four.
So this question said
what's the highest possible
value of X, it's 13.
But if it said what's the
lowest possible value of X,
then it would be the
high, the existing high,
minus seven so that you
can get a range of seven.
And so in that case you
would've gotten four.
But that's not what they,
they didn't ask us this.
I'm just, you know, in
the future you might see
a question like that.